good morning [ __ ] welcome back to hey
[ __ ] podcast we've got the regular
[ __ ] here as well as a very special
guest but let's start with the [ __ ]
who do we got
hey it's Gina it's Nikki it's Bo's it's
Tiffany and it's also Mia we have the
wonderful Mia here today I you know like
you've basically been in the news a
little bit more and doing some stories
and like I just kind of outreach because
I was like dude what's wrong [ __ ] and
we love strong [ __ ] we do love song
[ __ ] we love strong [ __ ] I looked at
her I was like I bet she smells really
good she does I was right I'm usually
spot-on about it bro yeah hugged us and
then once she walked away I could still
smell her yeah very enthusiastic hug I'm
all about an enthusiastic jog but yeah I
hate weak hugs I hate it when they put
their ass out and it's like whenever
somebody gives you the one I'm home I'm
just like only acceptable when they're
carrying something yes whenever they
give to me I'm like just tell me that
you [ __ ] hate me or like that side
arm Christian hug that's like really
mean you gotta save room for Holy Spirit
God then you it's the anti-sexual
harassment accusation hug like oh come
here
[Laughter]
it's hover but my fiance says Hoover but
he doesn't speak English very well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
second language which my first language
don't have way but we are super [ __ ]
excited to have you on like we we have
so many girls that like listen to the
podcast and I'm like dude we need as
many bristles as we can they just have
so much life experience and you know
you're definitely like in different
areas just as far as like pee
are like early career and everything
that like sorry I'm not supposed to
touch the table I'm gonna do the whole
pie path like this like you're sitting
inside on the anti sexual harassment can
cuff you under the table if this whole
episode like this
he was space for Jesus on the table okay
yeah like you just have so many like
life experiences that we like don't like
we haven't dipped into that experience
yet and then let's see let's go from
there all right yeah yeah unless you
want to start late tell us your favorite
colors okay so I'm crazy okay so I have
a question for you leh um what is
something about you that you wish more
people knew that I'm [ __ ] normal I
don't leave the house I don't party I
don't really only shower when I
absolutely have my fiance is not the
biggest fan of that but you know I'm
very normal all I do is watch Netflix or
if my fiancees playing video games I'll
watch netflix on my laptop and hang out
with my dogs at home so that's like a
normal Friday night for you that is
Monday through Sunday so then on the
flip side I feel like there's a
perspective of you that the public has
that is just not realistic compared to
like what that is yeah absolutely I
think I'm this like sex pop party girl
who's out and about doing everything
which is so [ __ ] wild to me because
you know your career in the adult
industry ended years ago yeah and it was
so good
it was so [ __ ] brief like and I feel
like you've done so much since then like
I've seen some of your videos and like
sports commentating and I'm like what
the flick sheen and like I mean it's
like literally down to the memorization
of like numbers and having you and the
way you speak about it too like you're
passionate about like sports and
commentating and like favorite teams
that rate so you mean she's a human with
layers that has interests outside of the
thing that she's known
so and like my question is like why is
it so hard for people to understand that
when you've really pushed that out so so
frequently at like I mean do you do you
know why some people might perceive that
I really think it's a vicious cycle the
more things I do that are mainstream the
more people are going to search my name
and look at those videos and it just
perpetuates us so let's walk it back for
the people who may not know the full
backstory how did this start what
happened what got you into porn what
when did you end it like all of those
things that maybe like it was low same
like I I used to weigh 50 pounds more
than I do right now
and I never had 50 yeah Wow yeah I was I
was a big girl I never had that positive
male attention from guys that I was into
you know I got rejected for school
dances yeah I got made fun of in high
school all that stuff and I just after I
lost the weight the first thing to go
was my boobs and they were this big
before I lost why does it happen that
way she has a perfect fire all day
making a point to walk behind her at all
I literally don't have a choice she she
recorded a video earlier and she was
like bows turn around literally said I
need to take bows to my plastic surgeon
yeah exactly just like I want this
bitch's ass not make it look like hers I
mean like literally take it off of her
and put it on I just want like the tiny
nough sand then the big because I bought
it right okay so you lost the weight and
then the first thing they were to go
over the boot yeah so I I only looked
like it wasn't just like I know I have
tiny perky boobs it's like no I look
like I had three kids they were sitting
at my nose objects oh my god yeah it
wasn't just like stretch marks I don't
care about that it was they were truly
just sad like extras
in yes people much excess skin that when
I went to my plastic surgeon he said
there's no way we can just do a breast
augmentation we have to do a breast lift
otherwise if we put the implants in your
nipples will be facing down so I had to
have a lift and then implants because
they were just so bad and after I got
that and I lost weight I started getting
all of this attention from men that I
had never had before and I didn't know
what to do with it I I felt like I
needed to trap it in a bottle otherwise
it was going to go away mm-hmm and I
felt pressured to do all these things
that men asked me to do because I didn't
want that attention to go away it was it
was so satisfying and it made me feel so
temporarily good about myself
that I started to do things that I
otherwise would not have had I been in a
healthy mental state let's say you felt
like you would disappear back into the I
mean we're not usually like this i
poison in LA this is my entire house
right now like I have a clean house but
it is infested with flies oh so annoying
you gotta get one of those Asian racket
thingy we do have it I made my manager
touch it the other day electric
flyswatter
he's behind the camera yeah so you felt
like almost as if you had two choices
either be unseen and note and get no
attention or do the things that were
asked of you so that you could keep this
knew yeah yeah exactly
okay that makes total sense yeah it's
like it's like your self-esteem suddenly
gets filled up to like 110 you're like
this feels amazing I don't want it to go
back to yeah but it wasn't it's not the
type of self-esteem that's the
long-lasting it's a very temporary
validation yeah that's extremely
unhealthy for a woman who was 21 years
old to have oh my god people are like
man if I could be a fly on the wall in
that room how to do it like
got that [ __ ] but you know sounds like
really interesting too because like you
know as young women like we're not
really taught that much about confidence
we're really not we're not taught that
much about confidence we were growing up
yeah I feel like now it's much more
prominent like keep to yourself be safe
don't be skinny yeah yeah make sure your
you don't like no butts not have don't
have a butt yeah does that cover up we
it was not taught to us to be careful
what you do we need your youth because
then it's gonna follow you forever
yeah times and do you you have really
expressed yourself how that's just you
can't shake that off thing no past now
it's been really hard so I'm also really
curious and like how you've managed to
handle that because it's something
you've been trying to put in your past
because I did see that hour-long
interview that you did and I was just
like man like you're so strong yeah yeah
yeah like I mean like and the other
thing is is that like I've there have
been so many people that worked in the
adult industry and then left the adult
industry and I'm like where are their
stories
you know and it's so interesting to me
that you literally like you know stood
up and said alright you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] talk about this like I'm gonna
own it I'm gonna talk about it and I'm
gonna let people know like what this did
you know to me internally and like share
my story that I'm a human and also for
other girls that are considering you
know entering that industry and it's so
easy now you know like with snapchat
it's like only fans and everything and I
I know some girls we're like I'm I've
seen they're only fans where they're
posting regularly and it's like like
total for this month four hundred and
ten dollars you know and it's it's
already out there and and it's it's also
in the scene I wonder if it comes from
like a the promise of money that could
come to you or if it's more along the
lines of wanting that attempt that male
attention and wanting to hold on to it
and not knowing where else to go
I feel comfortable speaking for a lot of
women who were in the same position and
saying that I really do think it is the
attention that they're seeking that
positive attention that they're
otherwise not receiving yeah did you
ever think it would blow up no
absolutely not
otherwise I wouldn't have done it right
once it started to kind of snowball is
when I stepped away and was like this is
not what I want
this wasn't my intention that start like
how did it actually become a thing them
oh I I was approached about doing it um
I saw me walking across the street and
handed me a business card and I went
home and kind of thought about it and
then I went in and took a tour and it's
not it's not so much like what you see
on those Netflix documentaries like
where it's you know in a dingy basement
or a multi-billion dollar operation like
in there they had a Starbucks I don't
think people realize like this is one of
the biggest industries ever like walked
like this outside offices shadier then I
concur sitting in cubicles with like
pictures of their families next to their
computer while editing a [ __ ]
gangbang scene yeah it was crazy to me
how many normal people work in the
industry then they get desensitized to
completely because I'm you someone that
would edit porn as like a nighttime like
there's their dirty dirty little secret
and stuff and then you just completely
would get desensitized yeah mmm sound
like wow that's interesting yeah my
friend uh my friend works out of one of
those offices he's like what he's like I
had to make sure the wrong for doesn't
go to a certain country cuz certain
countries have different borns that
they're not allowed to watch the [ __ ]
I'm like that is a really interesting
job you have there Wow yeah apparently
Korea doesn't allow spitting joking but
octopus tentacles are fine yeah yeah
weird and no joking
well that note on that note you know
what happens when after I watch porn
I get really no it's called hey [ __ ]
yeah you know I [ __ ] in the kitchen once
and you know what else I did in the
kitchen oh that was all the ingredients
were professional yeah yeah it was from
hellofresh actually it's a meal kit
where everything is delivered to you and
about
everything is pre-measured super cute
and it makes cooking delicious meals at
home in reality regardless of your
comfort in the kitchen so it's super
easy if he messes up I'm probably gonna
[ __ ] you up say goodbye it's endless
grocery store trips and take-out
hellofresh has you covered there's more
five-star recipes than any other meal
kit and there's like different ones
respect yeah and different diets yeah
they're like that war for your family or
if it's yourself if you really want to
eat a lot there's something for everyone
you have a family of six that's me I'm
the family of six I've had held fresh
before my favorite tell you guys all the
time is the pork chops and cherry sauce
one so for $1 off $80 sorry 8-0 $80 $80
off your first month of hellofresh go to
hell afresh calm slash b tch eight zero
and enter b tch eight zero again for $80
off your first month of hellofresh go to
hell afresh calm slash b tch eight zero
and then enter b tch eight zero yay yay
thanks Gina you're welcome oh dude I'm
so bad at listening I literally just
said thanks Gina okay you know I gotta
be real a lot of us have like you know
heard your story and like I said you
know watch the interview so we actually
know quite a bit about your story
leading up but I want to I really want
to like let you put as much out there
for viewers that haven't seen it just to
dial back to so you go into this place
and there's people with pictures of
their families in the wall editing like
what happened after that I went home and
thought about it for like two weeks and
then I called them and I was like okay I
want to do this amber what your concerns
were like think about this lighting out
okay but the more I thought about it the
more I was like how oversaturated is
yeah horn industry like how is anyone
ever gonna find out and were you like
there's gotta be girls that look like me
exactly exactly so I honestly didn't see
past that which was so naive of me but
hmm that's what made me say alright
let's do it mmm hold were you when this
happened I was 21 I was like freshly
treasuries well yeah they got
it's really young yeah so you know as
someone that like spent most of their
life like kind of like more insecure and
like you know you not the same image
body image this is almost like I don't
know for I was kind of chubby in high
school and lost weight too and like it's
almost like you've got to start your
life over a lot of the things that other
people experienced in high school you
were experiencing for the first time
like at 21 kind of a late bloomer yeah
yeah completely late bloomer I mean it
it wasn't just that it was also I wasn't
living at home so I I was living so far
from DC that I thought okay this is
never going to make it back that way you
know because that's how the internet
works right yes he's been the same place
on the same to me that you made it in so
you called him up and he told him you're
okay you're down to do it how was the
whole first time of everything was it
what you thought it was yeah no
absolutely not no way it was like I was
taken aback I had never been on a set
for anything before they had a robe with
my name on it
you know lunch was catered from wherever
I wanted there was like sparkling apple
juice because it's illegal to have
alcohol on set oh I learned something
new incredibly sweet girls who work
there were there with you the whole time
the makeup artist is so kind they go
above and beyond to make you feel
comfortable and then you kind of forget
what you're there for and all of a
sudden it's like dude I and it you know
what the thing is is that I had no idea
that the sets are like that and to like
really like lift you up and treat you
like that and it's kind of just to make
you feel like a lot of girls going into
it 18 19 20 that was the first time
they've ever felt like that special
before and it's it's trickery like they
know what they're doing is I setting you
up with that and they know how
susceptible you are like that's so
[ __ ] Scully is yeah so so you do the
first thing like after the first time
did you consider going back or my
adrenaline had taken over so any of my
fears and doubts and hesitations were
completely
just blinded by the yeah what God gave
you adrenaline oh I mean the attention I
was a well first of all I had never had
sex with someone that good-looking
before so that was it was adrenaline
from so many reasons from there being a
camera in front of you and all the
lights and lights yeah like just I mean
right now I'm like nervous sweating
because of all the light but you smell
great still how many people are in the
room with you it's just the cameraman
and like sometimes a boom mic operator
okay oh it's so it's pretty it's like
kind of bare-bones it's not like Love
Actually where there's 20 people uh-huh
yeah and so but then afterwards back to
the normalization thing after it's over
everyone's like hey great job great like
you know there's no there's no other
opinion it's just like yeah this is fine
this is normal and this is great others
are used to it I don't have any
girlfriends in my life at the time that
I could bounce this off of and tell them
what was going on and them to say no
this is not okay is the terrible idea
right you would have listened to them if
you did yes yeah yeah when you when you
have ten people saying yes and not a
single person saying no the only person
is you like you're kind of like maybe
it's not enough it's really not enough
and you know that's another reason why
like I thought of me early because there
were I see so often like right now how
we were seeing it's so easy to get into
the snapchat and the only fans thing and
it's really like glamorized right now
everyone's saying like yeah I make this
money do this it's so easy and you know
we're just not in a spot where people
can say maybe that's not the best idea
for you right now I feel like you know
some girls like they've got it in them
like they can make the money like
everything's people Drive in it yeah
they thrive like some people really own
it but then there are some people that
are like wait I'm getting attention from
this and I'm making money and you might
be hopping into it for different reasons
yes the sad part is as terrible as it
sounds if your beauty is going to fade
one day and what you're doing at that
age is going to be so detrimental for
your future and for anything you want to
try and
the future yeah yeah people don't think
about it I mean a lot of them going and
go into it so young and when you're
young you think you know every yeah yeah
you're gonna feel 10 years from now yeah
invincible you never think about the
future
Alex I didn't yeah I was young I never
even considered that one day I'm gonna
be like 30 or whatever I was down to get
pregnant at 17 yeah that's so ridiculous
if you really think about it you've got
a baby I have an 11 year old that's
that's the nice side about having a baby
so young you back that quick look at
this one she had a baby she was amazing
I also think there's some fame right now
like its clout yeah that wasn't around
when we were growing up but now like you
go to these conventions and I'll never
forget I was on a panel where Steve was
on it with my husband and he asked like
yes the crowd of kids like 13 to
whatever year old kids who and in this
room wants to be famous and everybody's
handling up right yeah and then he goes
who in this room knows what they want to
be famous for everyone's hands went down
yeah because they don't know they just
want to be famous they just know they
need followers they know and then they
get a little bit of attention from
something and they're like oh this is
the thing and I think that everyone
driven yeah important every single
person on this planet wants to feel
important one way or another and right
now this generation they feel important
based on the number of followers that
they have and I don't care about what
they're important for it could be like
something shitty like oh I robbed a
store and I went viral for it like
follow me bagel career yeah he was in
like a New York Deli like yelling at
women oh I thought you was slinging
bagels like this angry little thing like
he's like women always make fun of me
because I'm so short and now he's trying
to capitalize off of it like I'm gonna
box [ __ ] Logan Paul or some [ __ ] like
dude dude get off your [ __ ] booster
seat first of all oh all right I don't
like look like
you know people want to be famous for
like the worst oh really there's like
serial killers they love the notoriety
exactly getting published in the paper
and the shitty thing is people give them
that sometimes I saw some chick but it's
a selfie with that short guy like I just
met love of the bagel guy I'm like why
the [ __ ] are you proud of this yeah yeah
so I could totally see how people fall
into that and and I know like even girls
that wanted to be actors and then they
started getting more attention for their
bodies so they went more into like just
posing nude all the time on their
Instagram yeah whatever social media is
it's a dangerous downward spiral yeah
for sure yeah about that
how do I feel about it I'm completely
against it I think young women should
value themselves over anything else
themselves in their dignity well a lot
of people think that they could take if
I just get famous over here I can take
that and I can translate it into what I
actually want to do yeah like I can just
build this audience and then I can move
it over but is that the case absolutely
not I'm five years after you know
quitting porn and it is I still get nose
shut in my face and really like hello
fresh won't work with me
I get nose another every door gets shut
in my face because what about like like
a sex toy
type of brain oh I've been I've been
approached by every single one that you
can think of the fleshlight the Adam and
Eve all of them but I'm going back yeah
I mean that's easy money that's like I
could I could make so much money and
retire from doing a fleshlight but I
want to do something with my career and
I want to be a good role model so I'm
not going to go those routes what was
the turning point for you like that
moment that catalyst it told you like
you told yourself like I don't I want to
remove myself from porn when I started
getting all of the attention like you
know CNN writing articles all of like
everything that was coming at me from
the media terrified me what we're like
some other early headlines oh all of the
headlines started because I should have
said this when you asked me sorry
on the girl I'm sorry so I did a video
where I was in a hijab and it completely
blew up no pun intended because okay so
you did you did that scene yeah you
could write that one forever by the way
I love that I'm Catholic so I mean in my
head I was like why are all you Muslims
mad at me I'm not Muslim I'm not going
against my nature my religion like if a
white girl wear a hijab I don't think
anyone would be saying anything I really
have none fetishes every [ __ ]
Halloween and there's like poor news
like a whole movie were like brie Plaza
I love that movie they were so good
hilarious yeah I did tell the producers
though when they brought the script to
me I was like you [ __ ] are
gonna get me killed
and I was completely right because as
soon as the video was released I started
getting death threats on Twitter from
Isis from every Middle Eastern country
imagine all right and that's why you
started picking up on it like at that
point if you had that thought like what
what made you say well [ __ ] it I'm still
gonna do it though after because after I
voiced my concerns they just laughed in
my face and when a group of older white
men tell you that's not gonna like tell
you know especially when you're young so
intimidating takapa gun girl they call
me the into deep girl cuz I'm so afraid
of confrontation and stuff so I probably
would have done it too yeah it's the
same thing with ten people saying yes
and you're the only one saying no so
you're like okay dude oh my god okay
okay sorry I felt like I felt like if I
spoke up again mmm not bad things would
happen to me from them like I was I
never feared for my life but I didn't
know what they were capable of because
they were it
extremely rich extremely powerful men
this wasn't like you know some guy in
basketball shorts and a backwards hat
like they were in bespoke Armani suits
and living the [ __ ] life driving
their BMW m3s to work and stuff had
connections yeah in general its people
you feel like you don't want to piss off
yeah Gina on her face she look like
she's about to kill somebody she's gonna
find her two things I was like man
that's really shitty they sound like
[ __ ] but then also they sound like the
kind of men I want to date but okay so
these [ __ ] look you dead in the face
we're like yeah it's gonna be fine
because they're like oh we just want
[ __ ] do you want to work out is what
they healthy program to get me in that
mental state Gina hey Nikki and those
rich moguls or whatever I got a workout
program for you tell them Nikki it's
called Noom it's a healthy habit weight
loss app and they got you know physical
goals they eat better self-care
confidence and clothing more energy and
overall glow
you got psychological goals like healthy
choices self-worth better mood controls
anxiety and stress and you got social
goals like going out to avoid
temptations at home self control social
comfort trust your ability trusting your
ability to make good choices
mm-hmm so what's cool about new MS you
can log in you fill out all of your
personal information what your personal
goals are and then they'll actually send
you article as to why you
psychologically do those things and how
to help you break those habits goal like
it could have kept me out of point
[Laughter]
yeah so based on psychology they teach
you why you do what you do and gives you
tools to break those habits and you know
we're all strapped for time too but new
masks you to commit 10 minutes a day for
yourself they have really easy exercises
you can do just get those that movement
going and
one of the biggest and most accurate
food databases that lets you track meal
habits visualize portion sizes
and you see calorie density at a glance
so sign up for your trial today at noon
n oom calm slash b tch again visit new
mom slash b tch to start your trial
today that's Noom calm slash b tch
showing a car driving by I love your
mind I'm so sorry for what I am okay
okay so dead in the face and they're
like yeah no it's totally fine and so
you do the scene it starts blowing up
and then like was there a point that you
were like oh I would still go back like
what was the point where you were like
absolutely not like we're done here it
took me a while because I was
contractually obligated to fulfill a few
videos but once I started to realize
okay no one is going to force me to have
sex this yeah this contract is more or
less moot for laughs you know like no
one is going to force me to come in and
start having sex so I was really nervous
about what I would do after because I
basically had just my life had imploded
you know I knew it would be damn near
impossible for me to find a job after so
did you ever feel scared for your life
yeah absolutely
you know Isis is hitting her up do you
know that's her idea I have an email
address and a fact it was really a
hotmail account okay yeah right [ __ ]
Global CEO site website said it was
shitty give photoshop skills are so bad
no I have a child literally like yeah if
you're getting messages in that but then
also were you getting messages from guys
or was it like was it just like religion
in the country or were just other people
angry too it was a combination of people
who wanted to put me down people who
were angry
I mean for what I had done and people
who just wanted to cash in on the chief
joke hmm and you know the other scary
thing is is that like now you are at the
time you were like an adult-film star in
the like traditional media I like when
you're in the bubble of the adult film
industry then like there it's the
opinions are a little bit different but
then when you get into this bigger pool
here everyone's opinions are coming in
like Christian Bible Belt moms like
they're reading about you in the news
yeah it's a lot at one yeah yeah I mean
I I knew that it wasn't just men when I
was being approached on the street by
women also I say what who were like hey
I saw you I heard about you on CNN or I
read about you in Newsweek or you know
the post or whatever and they just
wanted to like come up and say hi it was
perfectly innocent the what it was
jarring was the men who came up to me
with a sense of entitlement to me and my
body yeah exactly so they think that
what they see in those videos is just
how I act when I go grocery shopping so
I've been followed to my car I've been
grabbed by the arm every name in the
book for not wanting to take a photo
with a man who approached me
disrespectfully yeah and it still
happens today Wow five years ago when
you quit right yeah it's somehow gotten
worse what I mean granted now it's a
little more diluted with people who
genuinely are fans of the sports shows
I've done or you know just my overall
personality on social media which is
very nice but it's hard for me to
distinguish a man coming up right
totally you know with terrible
intentions versus someone who is
genuinely a fan do you still get like
kind of nervous when somebody not
nervous but like anxious when someone
approaches you I'm [ __ ] terrified
yeah absolutely terrified which is part
of the reason why I don't leave my house
because I don't want to see any men all
of my food gets instant aroma all my
groceries get in hella fresh it's really
insane to me and I tell people this all
time it's so [ __ ] hypocritical you
cannot hate on something that you
actively consume yeah that is
but you can feel guilty yeah yeah
actually as long as they're hating on
you even though they consume it they
can't focus on them it's like you may
not do this to me
exactly yeah you're the name is a very
confusing human emotion oh that's
they're the ones he keeping they're the
ones who are keeping this industry alive
but you want to go hate on the people
that you're actively watching yeah it's
so [ __ ] stupid
and I think it's um it even speaks it
like Kim Kardashian made a video [ __ ]
like six hundred years ago and no matter
what she does nowadays no matter how
many people she actually helps she huh
oh sorry no matter how many people she
helps people are still like oh well I
mean she made a sex tape it's like you
get diminished down to that point of you
know yeah because people it's it's it
makes people feel better about
themselves to put you in a box not a
they're not a threat because they've
done this yeah mm-hm yeah I think that
also the the other thing that's really
interesting to me is that like even the
people that are that have found you from
the adult industry there are fans of you
they they're fans of you further all the
wrong reasons yeah lit it so it's like
even so of course we don't want the
people that are like hating on you but
then even the people that come out of
the woodwork and they love you it's like
but you don't know me exactly like you
you do not know me so it still feels it
doesn't feel fulfilling well in an ideal
world how what would you like to do to
move on like what what sort of a career
would you want to go into you know I get
asked that all the time and my answer
has always been I truly don't know like
I don't I don't know I'm 24 25 26 I
don't know what I want to do in 5-10
years in the long term but it wasn't
until I started speaking out about this
that I felt the most fulfilled hearing
stories from other girls who could
relate to me and it made me feel like
okay this terrible decision I made that
has completely put me in a hole and
ruined any chance of a career that I
could have in the normal world I could
do something good with this I can help
other women who are maybe on the cusp of
deciding to do porn or deciding to start
putting themselves out on the internet
like that maybe I can talk them out of
it because of my experience yeah that's
really why we put this
Casca together too because we noticed
like when we started our girl chat a lot
of us didn't have a group a girl group
to bounce things off of growing up and
then when we found each other and
started this chat a lot of the things we
thought we were crazy for or that you
know no one could relate to we all could
relate yo and bounce ideas off and and
then we're like you know if we did this
on a podcast there's so many voices like
yours like other and other people's
stories that yes you are helping so many
people out there just by sharing your
story just so people don't feel like
they're the only ones going through it
yeah or they could just be in a room
just like you were where ten people were
saying yes yes yes this is good this is
great like the money's coming on the
attendance coming in everyone's patting
you on the back but then they don't have
anyone else saying well I don't know
about that yeah and I think it's
important to to teach to people like a
lot of our audience is a little bit
younger they when you're young you're
still kind of like growing into your own
opinion instead of like what was taught
yeah and you like they just things like
well porn is discussing and porn stars
are Creswell by I hope that this episode
teaches them like like they're human too
they have feelings yeah snakes they do
good things and stuff like that um I do
I do want to ask you though on the other
side did any anything positive come out
of this maybe like even small things
like something that you met oh
absolutely yeah I never would have met
Jeff or my fiance if it wasn't for this
because I met my fiance from Instagram I
followed him he was living in Copenhagen
and then I was like you want a visa on
every foreign guy I see you know go find
a man in Europe they will treat you like
a queen dude honestly the one of the
best dates I've ever been on was with a
British guy those [ __ ] can beat
the [ __ ] out of ya put up with them
wearing really short shorts to the beach
[Laughter]
sorry we have some decent legs though
yeah aside okay so before your fiancée
now how did it affect your dating life I
didn't date Oh
I before him I had hadn't had sex for 14
months I had gone on a couple really
[ __ ] shitty dates I never dated any
when I was in what's a shitty date oh
just people who want to want it to be
with me or get to know me for the wrong
reason yeah like the type of guys that
they're looking at you you already know
they seen your videos exactly asking you
exactly oh and when they pretend like
they haven't it's the most obvious thing
yeah yes terrible so I was in a really
I'm at first I was in a really low place
and then I didn't I didn't uh meet
Robert until I was mentally in a
fantastic place I started going to
therapy I started doing the exercises
that my therapist gave me I started
spending time with myself and doing
things just for me not for you know the
benefit of oh maybe if I do this he'll
like me or if I do this like he'll be
interested mmm I just did things only
for me and only concentrated on myself
and growing my self-esteem on my own and
not really needing a man to define who I
am as a person so important because up
until I left porn men were like my world
kind of revolved around them and how I
felt about myself depended on how the
man in my life at that time felt about
me mmm and it's so interesting because
you like almost confirm whatever you're
feeling about yourself so if you're
insecure you kind of like attract men
who prey on insecure yeah you're you
know strong you attract strong men it's
exactly it's very interesting how that
works because it's almost
counterintuitive where you're like well
no I want to be who they want me to be
yeah and you attract the wrong guy when
my therapist first told me that I was
like all right go eat your quinoa that's
some hippie-dippie [ __ ] you're gonna
attract the people you desert like [ __ ]
off [ __ ] trap
yeah like quinoa it's also like you know
for the first rule after around 21 for
about five years of your life the
outside world defined you yeah because
we're so we we don't really know we
don't think too much of like defining
ourselves so what the world puts at us
we're like okay I think this might be
what I am and when you have so much [ __ ]
that's coming at you from different
angles it's hard to center yourself so
like did your therapist kind of teach
you to like okay shut out the outside
world and come back to yourself Utica
exercise like I'm really curious
honestly it was waking
every morning and writing down three
things that I'm grateful for and doing
the same thing before bed at night Wow
and the list just really humbled me
because it was the most simple things
like you know my dog fell asleep while I
was sitting up and like it was on my
shoulder and it made me feel so loved
and it was so pure and it was just
little things like that that made me
truly value my life and value the people
who I had decided to keep around me Wow
did you do you continue to do that no
[Laughter]
now try me well back in the vein of you
know just wanting to you know teach some
people a second opinion of just kind of
what happened to you after your career
in the industry what were some of the
roadblocks that you encountered after
leaving it was hard to get jobs and it
was really hard to get a job and the one
job I did have was at a law firm and the
partners there recognized me and I felt
uncomfortable being in the office and
thankfully that firm went under and they
did all whatever but then it was really
hard for me to find a job after that
because although I was no longer active
it was it was still growing like
wildfire like every everything that I
had done in the porn industry was still
spreading and more people were viewing
it like each day that went on and the
only job I could get was through a
friend who owned a construction company
you know like alright come be our
bookkeeper so I did that for a while and
that's when I kind of realized okay I'm
making sorry
I'm making $12 an hour this sucks I'm
not going to do anything with my life I
need to start capitalizing on this
platform that I do have and trying to
turn it into something positive so the
first thing I did was I left the city
where everything had been happening so I
moved away from Miami and moved to
Austin I knew one person in Austin by
the way literally just one person who I
had met on Twitter and she is the most
she's the best friend I've ever had
she's like how guys feel about each
other tell her we love her too long
Rachael Ray I love you so much
she's a Rachael Ray her name's Rachel
Ray Oh supporting Mia she really liked
she was my rock she helped me get
through everything and she the best part
about her was I never asked her to do
this but when we would go out and be
approached she would automatically go on
the defensive and take anyone's juggle
around yes we have Rachael Ray I'm there
Rachael longest [ __ ] in the pack then
I'm the mean one
like she'll do it she's mama [ __ ] yeah
I'm like I'm just security bear first
line of defense you don't have dogs
that's like that's Gina well you know in
order to stay healthy
I fight off the creepers that's right
and you should all get into a healthy
routine
give yourself to support this season
with a boost whether that's energy
better sleep stress control or something
else so our sponsor is care of it's
super easy you go online you take a quiz
about like what's concerning you is it
sleep is it your skin is it your is it
stress and it's basically gonna build a
package for you of what vitamins you
need when we've actually received our
boxes it comes in this cute little
cardboard box sensor it's like a
dispenser and you pull out the package
in each day and it says hi bosz and it
has all of my vitamins inside this
little package like it's super custom I
love it it helps exactly you know what
I'm trying to fight off and one of my
personal favorite things is the vitamins
are very high quality like I had b12
energy vitamins the energy was smooth
all day I felt good I felt like just
regenerated and I'm already out please
send me food I just ran out to I feel
like crap yeah all right the only thing
that I've done to actually help my
health and now I'm out Gina did you know
that for 25% off of your order you can
go to take care of calm and into the
code BT CH and
once again that's the code BT CH for 25%
off your first care of order yeah take
care of b TCH please send me more more
okay so we were just talking about
roadblocks that you encountered so
you're at the law firm it like it's not
really working out and then you decide
to take ownership of your platform yeah
so I moved to Austin and it was really
hard for me to like fully like I guess
finance my move and my new life that I
was starting so what I did for how long
did I do it for Jeff how long how long
did it how long did I do 11 months I was
a cam girl for 11 months and the deal
that they set in place for me the porn
company was if you complete 40 hours a
month we will pay your rent Wow like a
bonus yeah wait like any rent because
[ __ ] I'm getting a penthouse I have to
stay under $2,000 but in Austin yeah I
went a little over and like I paid out
of pocket but yeah I started doing that
and you know I still kind of hated
myself for doing it but I really felt
like I was just against a wall and I had
no other options at that point so it
wasn't until I took on Jeff as my
manager where he like within within one
month of working with him I was
completely done with camming I was
completely done with anything of that
sort so thanks Jeff get you a Rachael
and a Jeff he got me a sports show he
and you know he wasn't even a manager
before I poached him from this company
where he was just working as an editor
to me am I allowed to say that you were
poached your approach to be a manager
he went to Rutgers to study management
so he was definitely the greatest thing
that had happened to me other than
Rachel up until that point because he
completely changed my life and got me
out of that world completely and I'm
very I'm very proud of all the progress
he's helped me make know you're getting
now I just want to be able to like
understand it like is it people that are
like you you know what you did sign that
for oh yeah
you got powned really well for it do
people think you like you made lots of
money yes people think that I'm just
living the life driving a Range Rover
and rolling in millions off of the
royalties I get from the videos how you
feel with other people because after
that interview that you did and then I
started seeing articles come out of
women that are in the porn industry or
like they do amateur porn and stuff and
they're saying like I made $4,000 in the
and like did way less time than Mia did
and like they're kind of still pretty
much saying like you just didn't play
your cards right or like blaming you for
the amount that you need I mean I
thought that was kind of sad because
they are putting someone down that's
trying to move away or like move past
but because you're still in it they're
projecting their hate towards in a
bucket yeah yeah you know I don't get
the people I get the hate from the most
are performer born stars and performers
themselves well because you know you
said that you wanted to get out of it
and then you went back to kami and I
find that it is a vicious cycle because
they go they always go back yes yeah
they always go back to they retired they
realize they it's the only option for
them yeah it's like once it I don't want
to say it's like a nail in the coffin at
all because I think that as a society we
definitely can move forward to looking
past that but you know when you when you
get away from it and then you go back
you are kind of like after a while
deciding like okay I guess this is who I
am and you fought that like you fought
that very I mean it was terrifying it
was like taking a leap into a bank
account with very little into it
what the [ __ ] am I going to do if this
doesn't work out I don't want to go back
and ever do anything like this but so
now you're doing sports right you're
doing this for yeah Sports show yeah no
no I'm not doing a sports show I have a
sports app that's out and you have
another one launching in October awesome
oh and how is that going it's going
great I love it
we're shooting promos with the
Australian co-founders this entire week
and it's been really fun the first one
we from we released was called you Ref
and it was for rating Premier League
referees with statistics okay is a plug
or are you they can find they can you
because that's one of your passions and
like you can build a new career you
could start yeah yeah afterwards and you
don't you don't have to be stuck in it I
think that's almost fasted from the very
beginning though I made my Sports fandom
known because I don't know how to keep
my [ __ ] mouth shut
so I was always like live tweeting games
that were going on posting you know just
stupid commentary about anything
happening in sports pop culture so I
started to get a reputation for also
being a sports fan and at some point
someone decided to value my sports
fandom reputation over my tainted
reputation and took a chance on me yeah
that's awesome
keep an eye out for my M&M fandom it's
about the transition this career I don't
even know
are you a Juggalo what are you I mean a
gigolo wait have you seen that but just
tack back to like we were talking about
with the money I had I wanted to clarify
something that I think so there was
there was running on Twitter before and
it was seeing like you know me I'd only
need like twelve thousand dollars called
industry um and correct me if I'm wrong
in this but this really [ __ ] pissed
me off because the way cuz we work in
entertainment and I think that a lot of
the public doesn't understand how this
works were you essentially just paid a
day rate out yes that's how [ __ ] work
people the videos can be online forever
but she was paid out the day
that shoot and after that the videos are
owned by a company and there is no she
doesn't make any money people don't
understand it because porn is non-union
the people that they're thinking of like
actors and movies Bank off of movies
that is a union job in the factory they
make sure you get residuals and
royalties and write that stuff if you
are non-union and that's why it's like
you know dude I don't know if I want to
do non-union work it's because you get
paid a flat rate and for depending on
where you are at that time in your life
sometimes the flat rate is sounds pretty
good you know yeah I was like wow that's
like more money than I've ever made like
hell yeah I'm gonna take it and so you
know someone young and like especially
in the porn industry when you hear like
$2,000 you're like whoa like just yeah
that sounds crazy one two thousand
dollars to film one day right I can do
this forever yeah yeah like it might
blow up for five [ __ ] years my face is
gonna be plastered everywhere and I
don't make a single cent off it well I'd
be fine if it was my face unfortunately
for clarity like I don't think people
understand that and you know it to me
you are literally a person that was
taken advantage of at 20 and even now
they're still taking advantage of you
because you have more than two brain
cells just holding off you're like oh
she needed better management like most
of these girls don't have management
yeah think about management because to
be honest I didn't get into it for the
money I got into it for personal reasons
other women get into it for the money
and they don't want managers because
that manager is going to take a
percentage of your Carter Yanni yeah
like there is so much that goes on in
that industry that people don't
understand and so it blows my mind that
so many people are so opinionated on it
and they think that they know every
single aspect of it and even enough to
point a finger at anybody I want to ask
do you have anyone from your past or
like the porn industry has anyone come
to you and like been positive towards
you not just Nick because obviously
you've gotten a lot of negativity but
like has there been anyone any girl
that's rethought their career or yes and
that's part of the reason that I feel so
good for finally speaking out about this
because these girls who are in the
industry trying to get
you know have all these obstacles in
their way their obstacles are very
similar to mine it's just for some
reason I'm compartmentalizing it and
they are just lost and don't know what
to do they've reached out I had one girl
reach out on patreon who wrote this like
novel with her backstory and how my
story has you know kind of given her
hope and made her not give up and go
back to porn this time but you know if
things don't work out like she really
doesn't know what she's going to do
after and I've been in constant contact
with her since then like through
Instagram DMS just like checking in on
her seeing how she is and it's I don't
want any girl to feel like they have no
other options there are always options
and they're not they're usually never
the easy options they're the most scary
and hard thing to do but learn code oh
yeah HTML yeah and I mean also and I
don't even know I like I hope you
realize this but you are one of the
first people to do this to leave the
industry speak out on it and then still
stay in the spotlight and so now not
only can you talk about it but you can
show girls what's next how to move past
it like you know holding on to your
passion which is like sports also taking
ownership of like I am not defined by
this mistake and also just becoming a
strong woman that people can and should
look up to but I was it wasn't always
like that that's why it took me five
years to finally speak my truth yeah I'm
terrified of not just the backlash but I
was terrified that if I spoke about it
it would just drive people to look at
the videos more so I never ever talk
because for you you didn't get in it for
the fame a lot of like porn stars or
like you know industry people they get
it yeah we're the fame and so when they
tried to make a move past porn it's like
for the fame like it's yeah yeah Fame
but you're just like hey I just want to
be a normal person yeah yo like when do
I get to be a normal person again the
fame was kind of imposed on me and after
a while I just realized okay I either
turn this [ __ ] into lemonade or ice
yeah yeah I mean that's all you can do
yeah I mean like just overall I I'm just
I am always so floored by anyone that
goes through a [ __ ] lot and then
carries that load on their back and says
yep this is mine I'm gonna carry it I'm
gonna walk with it like I'm gonna keep
it rolling and I think that that is just
something that people really need to
respect you for yeah because you're
doing it you're doing it you're not
afraid you're looking at right in the
face and you're owning it and like that
that is a personality that is you that
like you are a strong person and
everyone should respect a strong person
thank you yes I feel like on the other
hand also we should I
there are women or I mean sorry adult
actors out there who truly do enjoy what
they do in the yeah I love it and I like
it there's nothing I feel like there's
nothing wrong with that too but people
should consider both ends and whatever
they they want to come into the adult
industry because there's there's girls
out there who are like I'm all about it
yeah but if you have that doubt which
you you felt that doubt but people said
no no it's fine it's fine if you have
that doubt explore that doubt like you
you really should because there is a
reason why it's there I also didn't have
the like mental resources to kind of
rationalize with myself it is okay to
say no yeah it's not it's not just like
I'm not going to put the blame on
everyone else who was around me it was
truly just me not having the like
maturity yeah maturity those yeah the
life skills and the decision-making part
of my brand like you trying to paint a
picture earlier when you know cuz you
said twenty-one and a lot of people
might go oh by 21 you should be able to
know blue blue blue but like as a like
late social bloomer when you're like
more of a person I got picked on in
school and you kind of kept to yourself
like coming out of your shell at 21 it's
like you're experiencing life for the
first time and like all those social
pressures that you would have gone
through you're going through like later
and so think of yourself like when you
were going through social pressures at
school like that kind of thing is or how
many people how many people in your high
school went to rehab before the age of
21 or before the age of yeah
like it was like a freshie like exactly
like she know better than to say
shouldn't you know better than to say
yes oh yeah frogs and all of that
everyone's a hero in their own story
like they just want to point fingers
when they relay them at 21 you're
probably still like chugging beers and
throwing up in your mom's bed you know
you're kind of well honestly we're so
[ __ ] sad you are but I think the
other thing is that like we had you know
we had research we had like watched her
interview so we knew a bit about your
story but it was also just so [ __ ]
cool to sit down with you and connect
with you like as another girl I was so
intimidated girls that's the most
terrifying I would literally rather deal
with Isis you know personally I take
that as a compliment to sweet today Mia
Khalifa said that she's more scared of
me that's fantastic no you're the
warmest most welcoming women I've ever
[Applause]
everyone like if you understand how much
of a dope a strong ass woman this is you
have something to learn from her drop
her a fall oh and all of her socials
literally like if you're struggling with
something tell her your story I mean you
said you loved hearing people's stories
Mia where else can we find you oh and
tell us about your app oh yeah yeah do
it you rat basketball it rates referees
it helps you bet on sports before the
games happen so download you ref in
October this should be out right around
then we'll leave a link in the
description too but thank you so much
for coming on and also thanks again to
our sponsors hellofresh Noom and care of
for $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hello fish right hello
hello fresh coms last b tch eighty and
enter b TCH eighty also thank you to
noon Newman's a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food their
personalized courses for your child
sign up today at noon in oo M I almost
said in New Year's Eve calm slash b tch
and for 25% off of your first care of
order go to take care of comm and enter
b tch make sure you guys also drop us a
follow at hey [ __ ] podcast on Instagram
Twitter you'll get to see some behind
the scenes content and I'm not sure if
it will be out by then but we should
have a discord launching soon with our
patreon if you need a group of [ __ ]
to talk to you about whatever you're
going through they're there join join
the game we're here yeah follow ups
follow me assure some love [ __ ] also
if if Mia if Mia's story
impact you [ __ ] leave comments tell
her how much of a badass [ __ ] she is we
need to drown out all these
[ __ ] that don't know what
they're talking about keyboard warriors
let's give her some love y'all hey I'm
scarier than Isis